buonasera in genere faccio un gioco alzi
la mano chi non ha mai sentito la parola
bitcoin però siete tanti vi posso dire
che la block chain è la tecnologia che
fa funzionare il bitcoin ed è una
tecnologia che oggi viene già adottata
da ibm da microsoft e da altre
importanti istituzioni anche banchi
scopriamo perché innanzitutto scopriamo
perché mi occupo di di block chain
beh la mia storia comincia abbastanza
indietro nel tempo ho iniziato sarà il
computer quando avevo sei anni ho
iniziato a scrivere a digitare comandi e
diciamo una volta si scrivevano i
comandi si interagiva con il computer
tramite interfaccia testuale
beh quindi era un linguaggio io parlavo
con il computer e dare un linguaggio che
mi piaceva attualmente perché quello che
gli dicevo di fare lo faceva al computer
e quindi era pre dvd era prevedibile in
un certo senso lo preferivo quasi al
mondo degli adulti
questa prevedibilità oggi è utilizzata
in moltissimi campi
siamo andati su marte con questa
prevedibilità abbiamo scattato delle
foto
questa prevedibilità permette a
determinate piattaforme di fare delle
cose che gli umani una volta fa cenno a
mano perché le facciamo fare le macchine
e perché è impossibile tornare indietro
perché quando un umano prendo una
decisione non sappiamo mai che cosa
accadde in quelle che chiamiamo la
scatola nera quindi non sappiamo mai se
un umano effettivamente sta per compiere
quello che invece una macchina un
computer fa perché gli abbiamo detto di
farlo
quindi in un certo senso la
prevedibilità dei computer sta supplendo
all'imprevedibilità delle persone ora
facciamo un esempio che non c'entra
nulla con i computer ben dietro del
tempo immaginiamo che ci sono due
cacciatori un cervo e due lepri questi
due cacciatori se collaborano possono
portare a casa a cervo possono cacciare
ma se non collaborano possono prendere
soltanto la lepre una per 1 ora
immaginiamo questa scena sono il
cacciatore sto cacciando il cervo
insieme all'altro cacciatore ma non lo
vedo non posso comunicare se faccio
rumore il cervo scappa
mi si para davanti la lepre cosa faccia
e soprattutto cosa penso che farà
l'altro cacciatore nella mia stessa
situazione
questa risposta viene dalla teoria dei
giochi
la teoria dei giochi è un qualcosa che è
concreta nella nostra vita quotidiana
lo siamo tutti i giorni anche senza
anche senza saperlo per esempio quando
prendiamo l'automobile
scegliamo la strada che pensiamo sia
meno trafficata o immaginiamo quante
persone come noi faranno quella strada e
su questa base
immaginiamo quanto tempo ci vorrà per
raggiungere la meta la teoria dei giochi
in un certo senso cerca di portare
ordine nell'imprevedibilità della nostra
vita quotidiana e umana perché questa
imprevedibilità in un certo senso può
essere pericolosa
le persone che girano con una pistola
negli stati uniti un problema abbastanza
grande per che si gira con una piastra
negli stati uniti e soprattutto l'altro
calciatore dopo che dopo che abbiamo
sparato alla lepre perché la teoria dei
giochi dice che non spariamo alla lepre
non ci importa niente dell'altro
calciatore del cervo e armato e al
fucile carico ed è imprevedibile
cosa potrebbe succedere
l'imprevedibilità e anche molto costosa
immaginate le persone che si mettono al
volante dell'automobile avendo bevuto
vediamo le macchine in giro camminiamo
nel traffico non sappiamo l'altra
persona che cosa sta per fare potremmo
pensare che quindi la teoria dei giochi
spiega in un certo senso tutte le
situazioni di imprevedibilità non è così
l'imprevedibilità umana e anche
controversa perché non sempre le persone
fanno quello che più conveniente per
loro stessi
immaginate che combatte per i diritti
umani immaginate tutti quelli che
svelano le informazioni che vanno contro
i loro interessi personali quindi
significa che c'è una parte di questa
imprevedibilità di cui comunque ne
abbiamo bisogno altrimenti saremmo tutti
i robot ok
guardiamo avanti parliamo finalmente di
bitcoin è di block chain i bitcoin come
è stato già accennato è questa
convenzione matematica che permette di
scambiarsi valore e denaro senza bisogno
di banche senza bisogno di stati un
protocollo che gira sui dispositivi che
un po tutti possediamo un po come il tcp
ip quello che sarà il protocollo alla
base di internet lo utilizziamo tutti i
giorni lo utilizziamo tutti i giorni
senza saperlo beh la tecnologia della
block chain ha delle caratteristiche
comuni con questo tipo di scenario
perché oggi a causa dell'imprevedibilità
cia ci affidiamo a delle strutture di
questo tipo ovvero un punto centrale di
cui tutti quanti ci fidiamo ci conviene
fidarci le banche gli stati i quali si
fanno carico di garantire che se sparo
alla r e non sparo cervo la dovrò pagare
ma il prezzo che tutta la collettività
deve pagare per questo tipo di comodità
è che quel punto centrale controlla
tutto cacciatori le prix charley cucire
tutto quanto questa è la blow chain ora
come potete notare sono tutti i puntini
piccoli perché la block cena siamo tutti
quanti noi potenzialmente com'è
possibile quindi che ci sia una rete che
non ha bisogno di un punto centrale che
controlli dotto quanto beh ci pensano i
computer ci pensa alla prevedibilità dei
computer perché il bitcoin un protocollo
matematico che scrive su questo registro
e distribuito condiviso da tutti quanti
quelle che sono le regole del gioco
scrive su questo registro distribuito
che se io sparirò al alla lepre anziché
sparare al serbo sarà multato dal
sistema
ok manca l'ultimo passaggio
chi è che fa rispettare le regole i
computer con la block chain
noi parliamo direttamente con un
dispositivo che possediamo con il nostro
puntino con il nostro nodo in pratica
noi siamo una fusione fra come macchina
grazie alla blog chain e quindi che cosa
succede che il cacciatore affiderà a
garanzia a riscatto una lepre al
computer il quale sarà istruito per dare
questa lepre all'altro cacciatore se io
decido di non rispettare le regole del
gioco
in questo modo ci troviamo di fronte un
sistema che non ha bisogno di un anello
centrale ma ha bisogno di una rete
distribuita in cui tutti quanti
se vogliono possono partecipare devono
mettere a gara nazionale pre ma in
cambio ricevono un cervo
conviene a tutti per il cervo
la situazione è cambiata siamo di fronte
alla situazione in cui mettervi un
acerbo arriva a fine giornata si
guardava al tramonto beh adesso i due
cacciatori stanno bene che gli conviene
caccia del serbo perché 16 non sparare
alla lepre vi costerà una lepre quindi
quella lepre verrà lasciata in pace ma
soprattutto quelli che ancora non sono
entrati nel sistema avranno interesse a
cacciare solo la rete prenderne una
mettere la garanzia del sistema e
cominciare a partecipare al gioco che
mette a disposizione un certo ora c'è
anche un altro problema per i cacciatori
disonesto
se alla fine io sparo sempre alla lepre
e ci rimetto sempre una lepre gli altri
non vogliono più cacciare con me e
quindi anche al cacciatore conviene
rispettare le regole senza che sia
costretto e teoria dei giochi non gli
conviene
questo significa che la block chain è un
gioco che noi a cui noi non possiamo
imbrogliare è un gioco con cui si
possono stravolgere completamente quelli
che sono gli equilibri nella teoria dei
giochi di nash possiamo avere degli
equilibri nuovi degli equilibri dove la
cooperazione spinta dalla convenienza
economica ma una convenienza economica
che non è guidata centralmente è una
convenienza economica che guidata dal
calciatore che con noi con la mattina si
è alzato e andrà a prendere un cervo
quindi è una forma di fiducia soltanto
nei confronti dell'altro ma una forma di
fiducia in cui sappiamo che all'altro
non converrà imbrogliare o semplicemente
sparare questa legge ora arriviamo al
punto abbiamo già tutto
prima si parlava del pantheon dei
miracoli in tasca noi abbiamo uno
smartphone uno smartphone e già oggi
forse la principale fonte di
informazione per la nostra vita
quotidiana ce l'abbiamo in tasca ora
immaginiamo se lo smartphone ci dicesse
che dobbiamo fare quella strada perché
se facciamo quella strada ci sarà meno
traffico per tutti
immaginiamo che lo smartphone ci dica
cosa ci conviene fare perché abbiamo
lasciato a garanzia
qualcosa deve probabilmente a qualcosa
che abbia un valore economico una
garanzia
una scommessa contro noi stessi rispetto
al sistema che ci comporteremo in un
certo modo e tuteleremo l'interesse
cooperativo di tutto quanto il sistema
perché semplicemente sappiamo che a noi
conviene fare così e agli altri che
partecipano al sistema conviene fare
così
pertanto sappiamo che a quel cibo gli
spariamo ma dobbiamo fare attenzione a
un momento cruciale
dobbiamo fare attenzione perché siamo in
un momento in cui computer potrebbero
avere il potere di governare le nostre
decisioni
ma come dicevamo prima possiamo
scegliere a quale sistema a quale block
chain aderire
quindi possiamo scegliere di aderire a
una block cena che non costa troppo
o che non ci costringe troppo il
paradosso è che una block chain civ
abbiano blog chain che non ci costringe
troppo sesso non siamo troppo selfish
egoisti quindi la blog cena non ha
soltanto il potere di pilotare le nostre
decisioni nel modo giusto ma anche il
potere di costringere ancora di più chi
è più semplice più attento al valore
economico di quello che fa perché nella
nostra block chain
dobbiamo sempre essere liberi di avere
il cervo davanti abbassare il fucile e
non sparargli grazie